welcome back to safety Ridge there take
now a couple of weeks ago skies deputy
per square toe Sam coats presented us
with some polling data gauging public
feeling about some of the issues related
to coronavirus and Sam's been going
through some more data and I'm pleased
to say he's back with us today with a
series of survey results comparing the
feelings among Britons with people from
other big economies around the world
some really interesting data here to
talk you through so let's look at this
one first shall we the question here in
the last seven days
have you had symptoms of corona virus
you can see there the percentage with
symptoms Sweden is the highest from 17%
followed by France on 13% 12% of people
in the UK say that they have had
symptoms of corona virus in the last
seven days compared to 11% in the US on
Australia and Germany on 10%
let's bring in Sam shall we so the UK
really in the middle there I guess when
it comes to how many people feel that
they've had symptoms of corona virus
absolutely well so this is data done
collected by YouGov in association with
Imperial College basically healthy
global study of corona virus and what
this question does and it's worth noting
that a number of countries were surveyed
about a thousand people in each country
between the 1st and 7th of April it
shows that really in many developed
countries the number of people showing
symptoms is bunched around the same
level except for Sweden now I'm sure
many of you are aware Sweden have
decided to adopt different rules on the
lockdown it's a voluntary lockdown lot
of compulsory lockdown and look at that
17% of people showing feelings compared
to a sort of developed world average of
around about 10%
so Sweden looking like an outlier other
countries rather than a week ago very
much all in the same ballpark just sure
that there will be a real Inquisition
about whether the Swedish reaction was
the right one later on as well let's
bring in the next graphic now shall we
Sam that we can talk you through now now
this question here is saying how willing
would you be to self isolate
if you were told to by the authorities
now all of these figures are pretty high
but you can see right there at the top
is the United Kingdom 95 percent of
people saying that they would be willing
to self isolate if they were told to so
Goldstar they're really for people in
the UK 90 percent in Australia 89 in
China 86 percent in the u.s. 82 percent
in Germany so the UK more willing than
the Germans to South isolative necessary
and India they're on 77% let's bring
back Sam shall we and I mean the
government will be quite encouraged by
these findings yes this is the evidence
that backs up the government assertion
that actually Britons of doing more when
it comes to staying at home self
isolating that even they expected people
willing to obey the rules it would
appear and expressing Anna confidence in
the authorities in doing that and I
think that this will be the fact that
the British believe in the instructions
given by the state more than even in
America and certainly in Germany which I
think will raise quite a lot of eyebrows
it's quite a striking figure the British
faith in the government for good or ill
seems extremely high that at this moment
that will be a relief to the government
and certainly a relief when they're
trying to flatten that curve bring those
very grim death figures down a bit of a
ray of hope there I guess and let's
bring in the next statistic shall we
let's have a look at the next data point
here now this is asking people how many
times did you leave your home yesterday
and of course a very key measure about
whether or not people are listening to
the governments of Isis you should stay
at home where necessary in Spain where
they've got a very strict lockdown they
are live in their home at the least just
nought point five six percent the UK
though nor point seven seven percent I
mean so that is less than one the u.s.
not point nine percent Australia just
over one there China one point five
Germany one point five nine and sweet
and where as Sam was explaining before
they have different rules when it comes
to a social distancing one point seven
four so clearly the highest there in
Sweden let's bring back Sam shall we so
people are leaving their house less
than once a day it really does feel as
if in the UK people are listening to the
government's device it does and in one
of the slightly lesser known notathome
moments of the press conferences last
week the government scientists admitted
they're actually community transition
the transmission which is jargon
essentially for the amount that it's
being spread in the community is now on
the decline the so-called the rate at
which it's going is less than one which
means that actually in communities
coronavirus is not spreading and the
rate is is going down and we are the
second country we seem to be the second
most impressive country to adhere to the
rules after Spain Spain of course you're
not even allowed to leave the house for
physical exercise that is allowed in the
UK it would appear that some people in
Britain don't even take up that
opportunity but again I think that the
authorities I think number 10 will find
this data heartening they'll be watching
this over the days and weeks to come to
see whether this number changes we've
seen every day the number of people that
are driving in their cars and going on
public transport released by number 10
in those daily press conferences but
this suggests that the level of
compliance again is much higher than was
expected even higher than in countries
such as you know Germany China at the
u.s. really interesting data let's just
look at the final piece of data then
we'll come straight back to Sam for the
analysis now this is that one that
perhaps is going to be slightly more
concerning than some of the more
positive ones that we've been looking at
the question here have you personally
been tested for coronavirus in the last
seven days Australia there 8% of people
so they have China 7% and then it starts
dropping 5% in the US 2% in Germany 2%
Franz 1% in the UK
let's bring Sam in is this a concern I
think it will be for many people now
this data is from just over a week ago
in large part before and around the time
that Matt Hancock said he's a hundred
thousand target nevertheless the fact
that other countries appear to be doing
so much better than the UK will strike a
chord I mean I think there are going to
be questions in this week's press
conferences
out about the level of testing skilling
use revealed yesterday that the capacity
on testing still is nowhere near what's
necessary that national coronavirus
testing center in Milton Keynes only
conducting 1500 tests today we're
looking to get to a hundred thousand by
the month it looks
she's won britain father thank you so
much for going through that data some
really interesting how to do it with you
again in future weekends too